ja die kultur sich dahin aber für andere
branchen läuft es eigentlich prima in
der pandemie zb für anbieter von corona
wundermittel unter uns leben tatsächlich
menschen die impfen für eine todesfalle
halten aber dafür quatsch kaufen wie
zistrose ein heilkraut aus griechenland
in fachkreisen auch bekannt als abzocke
des idiot ist im grunde eine art
kräutertee bei schnupfen dachte ich als
alte fahrer hörige schulmedizin [ __ ]
aber weit gefehlt meine damen und herren
sie glauben gar nicht wogegen das zeug
alles hilft der extrakt wurde getestet
gegen rotaviren bei hi viren ist er
effektiv influenza viren schon vor einem
jahrzehnt
wahnsinn eine pille und ich bin
geschützt gegen korona hiv grippe nicht
und lähmung wahnsinn müssen sie sich
unbedingt nicht merken zistrose verkauft
als lutschpastillen erhältlich in den
geschmacksrichtungen ouzo unterzog ihn
ja nur gegen dummheit ist bekanntlich
kein kraut gewachsen
geschäfte mit der angst vor corinna da
braucht man wirklich nur drei sekunden
ins netz zu gehen und stößt direkt das
tor zum wahnsinn auf ich kann mich ihnen
badewanne von in ihrem leben
ich kann mich mit ihren einschmieren los
dass im cistus drin ist von den
wirkstoffen das ist vom prinzip wie ein
schutzfilm was sich um viren legen kann
ja ganz blöd gesagt das ist wie so ein
kondom fürs - klingt erst mal
überzeugend und total logisch aber in
der praxis ist es wahnsinnig mühsam
jedem virus einzeln ein kondom über zu
ziehen weil viren sind ja sehr klein
astrazeneca bleibt liegen aber viren
presa werden gekauft
mein gott oder hier kennen sie schon mms
marke mini segment zu deutsch ätzende
teure scheiße chlorbleiche wenn ich eine
schwere krebserkrankung habe da würde
ich eher mms nehmen oder wenn ich corona
habe da würde ich auch er
es nehmen eine teilnehmerin fragt nach
einem mittel gegen ihren heuschnupfen
die tierheilpraktikerin empfiehlt drei
tropfen chlordioxid lösung direkt ins
auge
toll wieder brennende augen allerdings
auch nie wieder augen ja und auch legale
mainstream produkte profitieren
unglaublich von corona ich sage nur
nahrungsergänzungsmittel die waren schon
vor der pandemie ein fettes geschäft
2018 jahresumsatz 1,4 milliarden euro
und jetzt mit pandemie will natürlich
jeder sein immunsystem boosten wie es
nur geht ist ja klar
zum beispiel mit vitamin d dabei reicht
da auch dreimal die woche kurz vor die
tür gehen laut stiftung warentest
billiger meine klar kann das zeug bei
echten mangelerscheinungen auch mal
sinnvoll sein
tatsächlich futtert aber jeder dritte
deutsche täglich entsprechende pillen
oder pulver wahnsinns geschäft denn
gerade vitamine kann man überhaupt nicht
genug kriegen also hier haben wir zb 150
mikrogramm vitamin b12 brutales
portionen es entspricht dann 6000
prozent der empfohlenen bezugswert aber
reicht das
6000 prozent wozu ich kauf mir da auch
keine brille mit 6000 dioptrien oder ein
abhol sprits mit 6000 umdrehungen
denn wie man hier sehr anschaulich sehen
kann überdosierung ist gar nicht mal so
gesund vitamin b12 zum beispiel steht im
verdacht im extremfall krebsvorstufen im
körper schneller wachsen zu lassen
nahrungsergänzungsmittel gelten bei uns
als lebensmittel
ja deshalb müssen die hersteller im
gegensatz zu medikamenten nicht beweisen
ob und wie die wirken
wir brauchen endlich ein nationales
prüfverfahren eine höchst mengenregelung
gegenüber dosierung was ich persönlich
gar nicht brauchen sind sogenannte cbd
öle gerade auch voll der hype wissen sie
vielleicht cbd die kleine wirkungslose
schwester von marihuana jetzt natürlich
die frage was soll dann cbg hand fühlt
in einem cappuccino was bringt mir das
twd wirkt ja generell entzündungs
entkrampfen generell beruhigend und
diese wirkungen wollen halt viele auch
gerne im café warum trinken kaffee wenn
ich mich beruhigen will das macht
ungefähr soviel sind wie exzessive
baldrian
übrigens gibt es für die wirkung von cbd
öl genauso wenig seriöse belege für die
behauptung dass vitamin d vor cupid 19
schützt wobei es klar natürlich einzelne
produkte gibt die wirken ist ja logisch
sie futtern jeden tag säckeweise als
teure nahrungsergänzungsmittel und
fühlen sich trotzdem nicht gesund nur
ärmer kein problem für vollidioten wie
sie haben unsere forscher jetzt das
perfekte produkt erfunden
es enthält die vitamine pl und fw
männern es apfel apfel wege an
glutenfrei und entkoffeiniertem ihrer
apotheke der sechserpack für nur 299
euro praktisch schon ab
apfel das ideale nahrungsergänzungs
ergänzungsmittel und weil sich jeder
dritte zuschauer den kram einwirft und
jetzt vermutlich vollkommen verwirrt ist
brauchen wir dringend orientierung durch
olaf schubert gesundheitsmagazin olaf
gesundheitsmagazin olaf olaf hilfe uns
weiter warum inhalieren menschen
freiwillig das 6000 fache ihres vitamin
b12 bedarf 6000 wache ich meine bei der
homöopathie ist angeblich zu wenig so in
beiden nahrungsergänzungsmittel wie du
zu viel
ja also was sie nun das sind ja alles
mit empfohlenen richtwerte beim alkohol
zum beispiel muss ich sagen bin ich mit
dem 20 fachen der empfohlenen tagesdosis
ist bis jetzt sehr gut gefallen ebenso
ist es ja auch beim zucker es ist
erwiesen dass kinder ja viel mehr zucker
konsumieren als erwachsene
trotzdem aber sterben die eltern viel
eher als ihre kinder ja also man muss ja
glaub ich auch dran glauben das ist
hilft das eben wie auch beim thema haare
also nahrungsergänzungsmittel können
kein haarausfall verhindern aber sie
beschleunigen das neue wachstum ja mir
ist gestern abend unglücklich ein
wichtiges der kardec gebrochen aber
direkt daneben ein neues gewachsen
ich glaube quasi von neid ja also wir
hatten fest oft eher wirkungslose
kapseln verkaufen sich super
gleichzeitig aktuelle umfrage aus dieser
woche ein drittel der deutschen will
sich angeblich nicht gegen korona impfen
lassen das ist erschreckend
die sind möglicherweise beeinflusst von
dem ganzen bullshit der durchs netz
geistert da heißt es
impfstoff verändert unser erbgut impfen
macht unfruchtbar das ist natürlich
alles quatsch aber wie könnte man diese
leute noch überzeugen sich impfen zu
lassen
ja ich meine das erbgut das kann sich ja
auch zum guten verändern also ist meine
kinder werfen wir heute noch vor dass
ich durch fehlende impfungen meinen
erbgut nicht verändert habe und ich sag
mal so die mär von der unfruchtbarkeit
also da bin ich sehr skeptisch ich habe
wie gesagt viele kinder und auf den
zigarettenschachteln steht ja auch drauf
brauchen macht unfruchtbar
ja
ich hatte mich darauf verlassen und
jetzt stehe ich so dann also ich denke
man kann die impfskepsis nur durch
transparenz überzeugen ja indem man also
klar macht so ein impfstoff ist ja kein
hexenwerk
machen wir uns nichts vor wenn ich eine
pandemie stoppen will
wenn ich die deren ausbreitung
verlangsamen will was muss in den
impfstoff bremsflüssigkeit klar oder auf
dein profi tipp wie stärkt man sein
immunsystem aber ja das problem ist am
markt gibt es nur sehr wenig wirklich
seriöse produkte darstellt kaum jemand
etwas ernst zu nehmendes her außer mir
denn uneingeschränkt kann ich ihnen
natürlich meine turbomed forte omega
multiplus kapsel and more ans herz legen
es ist eine mischung aus
pure natur und rainer chemie also ich
arbeite natürlich in erster linie mit
der explosiven kraft des granatapfels
vorher natürlich entschärft sonst kommt
zu früh zur leistungsexplosion ganz
wichtig amalgam wurzel enthält viel
vitamin a ist natürlich sehr gut gegen
hepatitis b
wir brauchen unbedingt kokain wichtig
fair gehandelt logik ganz klar
laktat rettig ist wichtig für das sehr
wichtig fürs hirn gedächtnis und was
brauchen wir bleibt als natürliche
filter gegen die schadet das ist logisch
irgendwie bisschen spannend oder so
mögen uns und kuhglocken bürgen die
alles rein und das tolle ist es schmeckt
natürlich ohne zucker genießen ganz
natürlich mit dieser süßen katze und
kleiner tipp natürlich nicht das fertige
katzen kamerad aus dem laden verwenden
sondern die katze ganz frisch und hobeln
immer vom gesicht weg gegen den strich
in richtung schwanz liebe zuschauer und
wie das konkret aussieht das zeigen wir
ihnen in der ungeschnittenen version
dieses gesprächs im netz
dann fangen die katze gesundheitsmagazin
olaf
[Musik]
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
infobox
neben mir gibt es weitere interessante
videos verlinkungen komma vielen dank
[Musik]